eleven-year-old adarian Murray called
9-1-1 for help last weekend when his
mother's ex-boyfriend showed up at the
house instead one of the responding
officers shot him in the chest even as
his family says he was following the
officer's orders now the boy is
recovering and many in the community
want answers Omar villafranca has more
eleven-year-old adarian Murray still has
bandages where he was shot in the chest
Saturday by an Indianola Mississippi
police officer he didn't know at the
moment that he was shot his mother
nikayla Murray remembers the chaos and
confusion while holding her bleeding son
he was he started singing gospel he
started praying we started praying we're
very religious did you think your son
was going to die
Murray says she asked her son to call
9-1-1 after an Irate ex-boyfriend showed
up to her house around 4 a.m Saturday
morning when Indianola police arrived
family attorney Carlos Moore says
officers banged on the door and told
everyone to exit the house as a Darion
was following that order he went out of
his room and went twice the living room
as soon as I got a living room he got
shot by that same officer that told him
to come out he didn't have anything in
his hands or armed or nothing he had
nothing more and local media identified
the man who shot Murray as officer Greg
Capers he's currently on paid
administrative leave pending an
investigation
CBS News reached out to the Indianola
police department but they declined to
comment calls to Capers were
unsuccessful
a family staged a protest and sit-in at
Indianola City Hall demanding police
released body cam footage of the
incident
the family deserves answers and they
deserve it sooner than later you had an
11 year old boy come within an inch of
losing his life for CBS mornings I'm
Omar villafranca in Indianola
Mississippi